what age groups are you expecting
prince william and kate middleton made
their royal return to westminster abbey
on tuesday the duke and duchess of
cambridge met with the staff at a
vaccination center
that just so happened to be at their
former wedding venue
[Applause]
people from across the globe watched the
fanfare around their royal nuptials in
2011.
the couple will celebrate their 10th
anniversary next month
the duchess's wardrobe seemingly
commemorated the anniversary
kate wore a stunning cream dress coat
with intricate detailing that
certainly gave us those bridal vibes but
their visit to this historic church
coincided with a much more
somber milestone on the national day of
reflection
which marks one year since the uk went
on lockdown for the pandemic
william and kate spoke with the staff
and people receiving the vaccine
both the duke and his father prince
charles suffered from covet 19 last
spring
and they've publicly advocated for
people to receive the vaccine
well i think you're going to hear less
and less about the current state of the
relationship with the brothers for the
simple reason that every time something
is leaked to the media it sets
those peace talks back um we do have a
deadline approaching
and tragically there's another royal
milestone this year
come july a statue is going to be
unveiled
paying tribute to diana the princess of
wales and what would have been her 60th
birthday
it's unknown whether prince harry will
join william in england to pay tribute
on july
1st but we do know it's seen as a
pivotal moment for the future of their
rocky relationship
following the shock waves from harry and
meghan markle's explosive
interview with oprah winfrey and it's
really important
to the royal family but i think
particularly to prince william that
william and harry are there shoulder by
shoulder there is a lot of work clearly
to be done
for this relationship to repair but that
building of trust is obviously something
that's very very important i think
william feels that this is not something
that can be
carried out with a public slang match
and
who's saying what whether or not talks
are productive they want to keep it now
between them so i think we'll hear
probably
rather less about how things are going
between the brothers the real test
will be whether harry is there alongside
his brother in july
[Music]